The best way to release
stop missing or stop thinking about that person
hello I am Ivana your psychologist who helps you to heal
probably your mind
is cheating on you right now
and is making you that only
do you remember the beautiful moments you had with that person?
but what about the bad times you lived through
you may miss the happiness that person gives you at some of the stages.
or the happiness he gave you at the beginning
but don't miss the bitter pills
or the bad times you spend being with her
there was a reason or several that made you walk away from that person
so don't be fooled into feeling like it was a mistake to have left her.
don't give that person the opportunity to hurt you again
because believe me
it is better to say goodbye once and for all to repeat the same story.
and he himself was the pain of the rupture you first experienced.
remember that it was already quite painful to say goodbye the first time
and you really want to repeat that again
you really want to take a step back when you are doing well without that person
many times your loneliness will be cheating on you
but that doesn't mean you have to go back
take a second and really
think about it and think about whether you miss that person.
or you just miss feeling that someone loves you